this is a production of Cornell
University okay it seems like our
numbers have stabilized here so we'll
get started um welcome everybody thank
you for joining um we're um having
another session here of the hemp webinar
my name is beia if you watched the
previous one hello again um and uh I'm a
second year PhD student here in plant
breeding at Cornell University studying
hemp with Dr Larry smart um just for
your information these webinars are
being recorded um so you'll be able to
refer back to these and share these with
other people they're hosted on our
Cornell School of Integrative plant
Sciences YouTube channel I'll put the
link in the chat and they'll be um
posted um pretty soon afterwards so Dr
David such's talk is already up there if
you want to go back and um look at that
and thank you for our admin and media
team for helping me put this together
and get those um videos edited Kim Paul
and uh Craig Kramer big thanks to you um
also you can find more hemp resources on
our Cornell hemp website which I'll also
put in the chat as a reminder for
everyone if you have questions for the
speaker please put those in the Q&A box
and at the end of the talk the speaker
will go through those and um he'll try
to answer those questions if you want to
chat with each other you can do that
through the chat
function um so thank you for joining us
again I'd like to welcome our speaker
Trey riddle Dr riddle has experienced
working as an engineer a manager and as
an executive um he's an entrepreneur
that has founded and run several
businesses as well as built factories
and written research Publications more
recently he's gained a lot of experience
in biofiber
manufacturing and utilization at IND
hemp um which is an an American indust
scale hemp fiber and grain um processor
there he is the chief uh strategy
officer overseeing sales marketing and
finance he got his PhD at Montana State
University and his Masters at Cornell in
mechanical engineering so thank you Trey
for joining us today and I'll let you
get started with your
talk awesome well thank you so much for
the introduction and the invite it's a
it's a pleasure to be here um the slide
great well uh yeah hello everybody from
around the world saw the chat there for
a minute pretty exciting to have some
some folks coming in um today i' I've
been asked to speak a little bit about
uh the the hemp supply chain um and uh
but I want to talk for just a minute
right here about the goodness of hemp um
so I am from IND hemp and this is a
slogan that we used to we we like to use
the goodness of him means a lot to us
and and the people in the industry um so
we really to promote right is uh how can
we make things better how can we make
them good with hemp so it's a bit of an
ethos that uh that we live with um as
far as an outline where we're going to
go today um I'll I'll talk for I don't
know 30 to 45 minutes but uh but I
really am looking forward to having the
Q&A and and understanding what your
guys's questions are I think it's a lot
more meaningful if I can address those
specifically um and but I'll start with
talking a little bit about IND hemp so
you know who we are um the meet will
come in as we talk about a CO
coordinated supply chain and can look at
that in the lens of three different
sectors agriculture processing and then
markets uh spent a little bit of time on
Lessons Learned and and bottlenecks and
opportunities and strategic initiatives
um Davis Hof did a great job last week I
am less prepared than him uh I think he
gives a lot of a lot of talks as a
professor so I hope you guys stick with
me and uh what I say is relevant but
that's why we got the Q&A to to be sure
that you get what you want out of this
um a little bit about IND hemp uh you
know we are a family owned in an
operated business uh The Elliots uh
founded us several years ago um
originally looking at uh at at phyto
remediation Ken is a geologist that
worked in super fund sites around the
world and trying to figure out how to
clean up those those sites by
traditional means as a career but then
post that career started getting
interested in hemp as a FAL mediator um
he actually owns an old Refinery site in
in Montana but then uh then actually
found out about the great things
happening just across the border in
Canada um around grain and the need for
Alternatives um in our you know in our
Farmland here in the US in Montana
specifically uh and the applicability of
what was happening in Grain up there so
I hemp actually started as a as a hemp
Grain Company Kim convinced his daughter
uh Morgan to join on she she came from
the other side the Dark Side from ADM
Archer Daniels Midland uh where she was
a chemical engineer there working in
large corn and soybean uh processing
facilities um and she came over to have
some fun with us uh here at IND H and
founded IND
H we really take uh our ethos seriously
people plan it and and profit pretty
much in that order uh what you see on
the screen here is a is a picture of
Fort bitton Montana that's where I am
today
Central Montana in the in the prime
growing region what we call the Golden
Triangle called the Golden Triangle
because so much wheat is grown here uh
Fort bitton was uh sort of a Pioneer
town it's how Montana and much of
Pacific Northwest was was settled the
steam ships would would come up uh the
Missouri uh the Mississippi River to the
Missouri River and basically couldn't
get any farther than Fort Benton and so
a lot of history here uh so it's a great
spot to to Pioneer him as well a tal of
13400 people uh primarily supported by
Agriculture and then a little bit by
tourism having our infrastructure here
is really meaningful you know to the uh
to the town and to the region both in
terms of employing folks directly into
the company but then also supporting
acreage uh in the region uh we really
you know live behind that uh to to be
supportive of our people then also the
planet we think what we're doing here as
as I hope everybody on the call does uh
is is Meaningful and that we're we're
looking at new ways to implement
agricultural solutions to some of the
world's problems be that food or uh non
sustainable materials and
whatnot um and you know our vision our
mission as a company um really has a lot
to do with the talk today uh which is
you know connecting that that innovators
at the agricultural level uh with the
pioneers in in industry and that's
really what this value chain is all
about right is how do we go from a a
commodity off the farm to something that
a consumer can actually use and um takes
a lot of dots to get connected you know
to do that and everybody has to uh be
rewarded and see value along the way and
so our vision is really to create a a
supply chain that's profitable and
sustainable and we really do value and
lean on our personal relationships I
wouldn't be here today if it wasn't for
other folks in this industry and other
Industries you know caring about what
we're doing and engaging um we actually
come back to that a little bit at the
end of this talk and how meaningful that
can be in building uh viable Supply
chains um we're pretty Diversified in
hemp space uh at least in the industrial
hemp space that is uh we don't do
anything in in CBD at all U but our
product lines are hemp seed Foods uh
hemp feed and and animal supplements and
then hemp fiber so gives us pretty
Diversified portfolio um of activity
there to uh and to support diversity on
the on the farm as
well I want to make a shout out here to
gentleman Pier barard that we had the
pleasure of working with over the last
couple of years um he has written a
report and published it on his website
biosolutions initiatives I encourage
everybody to go take a look at the
report I mean it's free and it's an
amazing uh resource uh I actually uh uh
grabbed a number of his images and
whatnot because I think they speak
directly to some of the the conversation
that's happening here around Supply
chains and how we can make viable
lasting Supply Chains It's a little bit
of plagiarism but I worked really close
with Pierre on some of this and I think
he uncovered some some some really
important uh you know lessons on how we
can make this this work so um check that
out check the report out check his
website out reach out to him he's a
great
guy uh so you know what we'll talk about
today is is the supply chain and in
essence what is really needed is a
coordinated supply chain right we can't
we can't do this in a bubble uh
individually um you know we all need
customers we all need suppliers that's
at every level of the supply chain and
uh you know I like to say that we're not
really building uh we're not building
just a company we're building an
industry and we're doing that from the
ground up uh and that really results in
integrated and dependent Supply chains
unfortunately they're also pretty
complicated and and presently a bit
fledgling right we're still a little bit
immature but this graphic does a decent
job of showing how the foundation you
know is the farmers and there can to be
a lot of farmers uh that might support
you know um a limited amount of
processors which which then go on to
support Brands and consumers and these
Supply chains uh start you know
regionally and then they become
nationally uh and then even
International to some degree for sure as
we look at the growing us industry uh
supporting export um but uh but it's
really you know the foundation is is at
the farm level and so so why we would
say it's starts on the farm um this is a
this is one of our Fields here one of
our Farmers Dale Flicka this is a a
fiber crop um this is an Asian variety I
don't remember which one on the picture
probably yma or Hani one of the two um
but um it starts in the farm right and
that's the foundation Supply chains so
Agronomy and production is critical um
but it's more than that right it's you
know it's the contracts it's the
relationships it's it's the support So
at IND hemp we' we've actually grown
we've contracted for over 30,000 acres
to date over the last five years or so
um typically it's about 50% organic um
on our on our grain side of the business
not as much on the on the fiber side
there um and so you know we had a lot of
experience and we've had a lot of
growing pains into what that you know
what that means um to be successful
we're still learning a lot there's still
there's still more to learn um but at
the end of the day you know
fundamentally I I think these These are
sort of self truths that everybody
probably knows but just to reiterate
them here there's got to be you know a
market for the farmer right the farmer
needs a buyer and you know and is spot
buying is is difficult and of course we
saw some travesties in the early days of
the Industrial Hemp uh around CBD and
and other uh other Commodities as well
but um the end day the farmers got to
sell their products just like you know
everybody else has to sell their their
product so they have to have contracts
that are meaningful to them uh and those
contracts really need to you know
encourage some support um the farmers
need a viable production model um and
it's different you know it's different
on where you are and you know what
you're growing for um and it's really
you know I think it's an understated
need for uh the processor the buyer to
help you participant in that support
infrastructure right so uh we have
agronomist on staff I mean I think he
puts like something ridiculous like
40,000 miles uh you know windshield time
just D driving around to our Farms you
know repeatedly throughout the year
whether that's in the early information
stages of of what our contracts look
like compared to their other
Alternatives um you know to making sure
the seeds are getting planted right and
fertilization and and harvesting is a
big deal um very challenging I mean um
you know we do both grain and fiber and
we're actually at the point now where we
provide harvesting Services essentially
you know cutting raking and bailing for
the straw uh considering it's 12 feet
tall and that was a need that sort of
arose out of um you know maybe a lack of
experience with hemp as a fiber crop and
a lack of tools right what are the right
tools and then you you know is one
farmer going to buy that tool it's very
challenging for them to buy a
specialized cutter if they're only going
to grow 40 or 250 Acres right uh we
leverage what we can from traditional
implements but uh we found is actually
pretty necessary both for having the
right tool for the job then also
managing um the right timing and
practices for the harvesting so um at
any rate Pharmacy a viable production
model so they know they can be
successful that they need the right
seeds at the right price this is also I
think an understated uh need for the
industry
um not all seeds are created equal and
some are good in some areas uh climate
and soil conditions and uh some are good
in others and some are good for
obviously for grain applications some
are good for fiber applications um and
then some are just too dang expensive to
make the whole model work and so this is
still a need and we've we've identified
a couple that we focus on uh that work
and you know for the most part in those
metrics for our models it's going to be
different for everybody in every place
um you know proximity matters um you
know I think this is sort of obvious as
well but um it's most critical for straw
um you know the transportation cost for
straw bills can get expensive grain is a
little more flexible you can move grain
a little bit further um this is the map
of our some of our Farms you know we're
located here in Montana um but we do a
little bit in Idaho Washington and
Oregon as you get further away up to
maybe 400 miles away those are almost
exclusively grain contracts whereas the
straw uh is is quite a bit closer and um
you know I think you you think about
traditional Commodities grain elevators
are every County right has a grain
elevator um we're not at that scale yet
but as far as processing infrastructure
you know the transportation costs and
the support system has got to be
Regional in nature um you know for the
farmers but that doesn't not only does
that need to take into account um you
know the the farm conditions and the
farm economics and and climates noral
conditions infrastructure all those
things it also needs to consider the
regional U markets and hotspot activity
right because there's also a cost to
getting to Market and there's an ease of
getting into market so Logistics both
from the farm to a processor but from a
processor to Market all need to be
considered and that may drive decisions
right all of our decisions should really
start at the market level who's buying
something why do they need it you know
what's it what's it look like how much
will that pay and then work that way
down the value chain and that actually
has a place at the farm level quality
and cost and and proximity are all
factors
there um if we look at you know out of
Agriculture and into that next level of
supply chain uh processing we can look
at it a couple different levels but the
first level is sort of primary
processing primary agricultural
processing or first tier processing um
here at IND hemp like I said we do both
um fiber and grain uh so these are
fairly significant you know
infrastructure Investments on the left
is the fiber facility um it's about
52,000 Square ft plus about 8 Acres of
outside storage uh for the decortication
the Milling classify and packaging and
then on the uh on the grain side uh got
about 177,000 square feet where we have
grain cleaning um you know crushing
dehing uh and milling and packaging and
the uh the role here of the first you
know first touch processor obviously is
to take that raw agricultural goods and
and convert them into more of a value
added a product that may still be an
ingredient um or could be a finished
good you know possibly depending but um
but this is you know this is more
centralized processing with larger
Investments uh to to achieve some scale
um you know there are there are lots of
folks uh at the farm level Farmers that
have invested in Technologies they can
Implement in their uh you know in their
barns or or shops or whatnot and that's
just a different style of of processing
and and hopefully there are I think
there are opportunities for that more
distributed um processing infrastructure
um to get more value into the farmers
hands but it's always that duality of of
scale you know economics capital
investment and whatnot um you know but
we've seen Time and Time Again Farm to
Table being successful uh for hemp it's
a you know this is a little bit more
challenging than say for um you know
cattle or something like that where
there's a large buyer infrastructure out
there of you know of slaughtered meat so
um this is kind of where we landed is is
to centralized processing large scales
to do value ad to the raw Goods um and
that's because scale matters uh from our
perspective to get to those economies um
and there's uh generally you know while
uh the industry will beg borrow and
steel from other other Industries the
hemp industry will use equipment that
had a different purpose right it might
have been for textile processing or it
might have been for soy being processing
or whatnot but but almost always these
are purpose-built systems systems that
have been you know engineered uh for
hemp whether that means at the systems
level where you just put the right
pieces of the puzzle together or you
modified one piece of equipment to do a
thing um there's really you know there's
really no not there's not a lot of
success in sort of one you know TurnKey
off the shelf piece of equipment to do
what you need it's it really comes down
to that systems engineering component um
and uh one thing I think that a lot of
people don't consider as much as we
should on the front end of getting into
the processing business is packaging so
one of our goals as as processors in
that intermediary between the farm and
the markets to ensure we have adoption
we need to be able to give the market
something that they can use um you know
and of course that comes down to the
performance of the material the
compatibility of the manufacturing or or
whatever of that material um but also
packaging has a big role in that right I
mean if you have a a buyer that's buying
whatever um you know soybean meal or
talc in a certain packaging format and
you're asking him to switch to hemp
that's already one ask if you're asking
him to switch to a different packaging
unit that's another ask um and so that
can be challenging too um one we should
attempt to minimize the um you know the
hardship on the buyers if they're if
they have to switch from incumbent
material to uh you know to hemp and um
that'll just make it easier for us to
you know to get into the market uh one
thing you know in our systems is trying
to be automated right how do we uh
minimize the touch points how do we
ensure um Quality Control uh and move as
fast as possible because uh that's the
name of the game right uh is uh is
pushing as much material through the
lines as possible to get the cost down
and automation becomes a you know a big
deal for that um and then you know
quality is is as well I mean I think you
know quality relates to Performance and
we've got to be competitive with the
other items on the market uh to be you
know uh to be
successful the other piece to this sort
of Middle Ground between markets and and
or end markets and consumers and the raw
materials are are con what I'll call
converters which are sort of second tier
processors right um so these are these
are groups that might buy you know
decorticated fiber from a decortication
line they might buy uh you know protein
from a seed mill um and the reality is
is is these guys need love too um they
need they need Investments they need
reasons to switch to hemp they also need
opportunities as well and um so this can
cover anything from non-woven lines
making uh Felts to feed mills for cattle
or spinning Mills for textiles pulp
Mills for paper um food manufacturers
and co-manufacturers composite
manufacturers uh but you know this is
probably not talked about as much as I
think it should should be right is what
are these I mean the reality is we we
might not be able to deliver something
that is a 100% drop in replacement to
the incumbent material so what do these
converters need to do or do we need new
converters that um that maybe a hemp
specific spinning Mill right um because
the challenged all the spinning Mills
out there today have spent 100 years
optimizing around short staple cotton or
or wool or whatever but it wasn't him
right uh so you know do we need new
infrastructure um that can be f focused
on him I think it's a it's a valid
question and likely a valid need um but
also there are you know there is
infrastructure out there today that we'd
like to see adopt hemp and so that's the
other piece of that but um they need
investment and they need support as well
and and in many cases those those
companies are interested because they're
looking for more market share uh but it
can take time and take a lot of work um
and and these are Giant Markets as well
I mean you know we're talking about
hundreds of billions of dollars for
these products not that hemp would have
um you know you billions of dollars
opportunity I think some people might
say it would but um but the point is
just that there's a lot of space and
there's a lot of prerogatives that are
happening now that are you know are
driving the desire whether it's for more
sustainable materials um but I think one
of the goals is to try to find the
places you know where there is growth
like what what Market is growing because
it's easier to penetrate a a growing
market and sort of feed off the growth
rather than a declining or stagnant
Market um where you're you know a true
replacement to you know to existing um
materials and
infrastructure so um that brings up some
questions about you know how do you how
do you go to market I think in that in
that supply chain and what are the
markets and so one thing I think that we
found that was successful is to look at
vertical in integration um often time
that's needs a supply chain partner uh
to get that over the the goal line
um whether that's through contract
manufacturing you know to um you know to
make um a salad dressing or whatever out
of your you know your hemp oil or
whatnot um or a non-woven mat um for
erosion control whatever it might be
lots of times we can't do all that
inhouse sometimes we can um you know and
and that could be a finished branded
product uh which is what we've done in
some cases is is develop you know in
consumer products primar in the animal
space it's a place where we found
success um whether that's through
bedding or nutritional and supplement
products um but you know the the uh sort
of the benefit of doing that is is
balancing that sort of that lower margin
large scale B2B adoption with higher
margin you know you know finished
products but with that is a whole
another level of of um operational needs
for the company to uh to integrate and
and for us us both are critical I mean
the sort of that large scale B2B uh bulk
sales are necessary to achieve the
economies of scale um you know so that
we can actually make the stuff at an
affordable price but then the finished
goods enable us to capture some more of
the margin but but um but we actually
needed Partners to do that so we we
launched in that space with a local
retailer in uh in Montana and Idaho
called North 40 and so they kind of
helped direct us on what a brand might
look like and and what are the packaging
units on the store shelves what are some
of the other uh opportunities uh or
other options out there that we'd have
an opportunity to support or replace um
so that customer buying was extremely
critical that customer Discovery and us
making decisions to you know to launch
our you s our first branded product and
since then we've learned a lot and we
we've grown uh you know beyond that but
uh but having that partner on the front
end uh was really critical so it's
definitely something we found successful
I think everybody else would and that
that sort of led to us developing two
different uh branded lines we have a
farm and ranch line called himana and
then a a pet line called all walks um
and so that way we we have different you
know similar products different
packaging formats or sizes uh different
you know different markets pet would go
into specialty pet stores like a Petco
or petmart farmer Ranch into Tractor
Supply type stores
um but the other thing that kind of came
along with this is um you know this
required us to obviously invest in
packaging infrastructure but also brand
and marketing as well and then you know
that should be understated and so one of
the things we also do is we utilize that
infrastructure and that knowhow to do
private label for others um you know so
that's a way to diversify some of our
you know our operational needs and
revenue opportunities and support other
companies uh in the process as well to
get their brands out there or support
their region and um you know we can't
really do it all ourselves right and so
you know I think in the future we'll see
more distributed manufacturing come
online
um you know so I like talk a little bit
um uh about Farm you know what do we
really think we can achieve here in the
in the hemp industry what that means and
and how we get there um so one thing I
think is is worth sort of uh mentioning
here is uh you know the countries that
have uh the larger hemp cropping acreage
um for one they either neither they
didn't ban production or they restarted
earlier and so China um never having ban
production you know they're looking at
this is data from 2020 uh but it's not
terribly different in
20122 um but China in the 160,000 acre
range uh France and Canada they
restarted earlier France in the 1960s
and Canada in the late 90s of of
reinvigorate their their hemp
um you know their hemp opportunity and I
think that's sort of telling right I
mean France started in the 60s and
they're looking at 46,000 Acres Canada
late 90s and 55,000 Acres so um you know
20 25 years I mean uh 60 years these are
long time frames to get to what arguably
in the scale of agricultural Commodities
isn't that many acres right and so I
think there's some question out in front
of us um you know as we as we look at
this data is well what how can we do it
faster how can we do it better how can
we do more right how do we how do we get
more value more demand for hemp um and
in order to do that it's kind of
necessary that we look at some of the
other Supply chains that were built and
figure out what we can learn from them
um and they're complicated right so I
mean it it covers an enormous amount
this for for a new industry like hemp
you know an enormous amount of touch
points right and uh whether that's um at
the farm level the processor specialized
equipment um Logistics you know there
storage I mean R&D genetics I mean it's
just it's a very complicated industry
that really needs coordination and it
also needs Capital at at different
stages um of the supply
chain and so we you know we think about
that say okay well it's complicated
there's a lot of moving you know factors
a lot of different places how do we
exped
success and reduce that investment cost
um I think it's impaired that we look at
other countries and we look at other
agricultural Commodities and so um this
is actually what the report that Pierre
put out there did a good job of spelling
out so um the next few slides here I'll
kind of uh grab some stuff from from him
um make sure I give him a shout out
there but I think they're it's really
good information that uh not everybody's
aware of um so we'll start with France
so um like I said France started in the
60s you know they're at 50,000 Acres or
so about you know now um and they
probably have the most Diversified
industrial value chains as Rel to
products and and markets um in the world
um China you know almost exclusively
textiles right Canada almost exclusively
uh grain and food whereas France has a
lot more diversity but it took 50 years
for them to get there and I can tell you
um in spending some time with one of the
larger processes over there um it took
them 18 years to get to break even and
those are pretty sobering you know
sobering remarks I think that we should
all consider and so how do we learn from
that you know how do we how do we
accelerate it because um you know we
might not have the appetite uh you know
or the ability to uh to last that long
for some of us um so one of the things
in France is uh they had cooperatives
every pretty much every uh hemp uh
industry member in France is part of a a
cooperative
um and that ensured farmer buying in The
Prudent Progressive development to
create value to the farmers right if it
doesn't work for the farm doesn't work
for everybody it doesn't work for
anybody right um but Farmers have a lot
of other options right they have a lot
of other things they can grow so and
that's the foundation that we have to
build on so having their buying at the
beginning uh is is extremely useful in
ensuring that we have a suable and
stable and sustainable supply chain um
furthermore several groups of processors
came together to pull resources um you
know and to invest in activities and
sometimes that was with external
Partners but they sort of aligned and
said hey like we all got some of the
same problems um maybe we should work
together on those we all have some of
the same opportunities you know maybe we
should work together on those um and
that's difficult right that's a
challenge uh I think for us to let our
guards down but it could be one of the
most instrumental ways we can be
successful uh they're also booed by
favorable government relations or
regulations um you know in France and in
the European Union at large in time um
and uh that allowed the industry to
expand and uh one thing that is is kind
of Cornerstone um in Europe and
specifically in France are subsidies for
hemp turns out they get about you know
anywhere from 60 to $76 per acre in
subsidies for growing hemp split between
two different subsidy programs um that's
pretty significant I mean that's that's
essentially
um the bottom line the the profit margin
uh for a farmer um so it's very
meaningful and you know we obviously
don't have that and we may never have
that uh in the US but regardless it's
good to understand what some of those
levers were in other places and how they
are
successful we should also look at other
agricultural Commodities you know in in
the United States and and North America
sort of three that sort of stand out in
the uh the last century for growth are
cotton sugar beats and soybeans as
potential models um for how we can build
you know our supply chain um cotton
arguably you know was was the most
successful in garnering um government or
Congressional uh support um and that was
in large part uh function of cotton be
the go-to fiber um you know in the early
part of the 19 20th century and then
synthetic fibers coming around the mid
part of the century uh displacing
enormous market share for cotton and the
saying oh boy this is a bit of a problem
we got a lot of farmers growing cotton
we got a lot of infrastruct
infrastructure um dedicated to it and so
um you know an Act was actually uh
passed to support cotton research and
promotion then cotton Inc came on board
um with really a dual strategy to to get
that market share back by both pushing
Innovations um through by supporting
research and development um but then
also uh building customer Demand by
advertising you know pulling through so
you've seen the you seen the cot logo
I'm sure in placees not not so
dissimilar to to got milk or um where's
the beef type of campaigns uh in the
past right so uh sugar beats is another
example where Farmers banded together in
associations and and cooperatives um and
that enabled them to share a lot of the
lessons learn uh to pull um you know the
uh the processing infrastructure I mean
most they're almost all cooperatives and
then the Cooperators join together in a
Cooperative uh to form you know United
sugar and whatnot um you so they achiev
some stability there and their ability
to um present a more unified um source
of Supply you know and saying well we're
not just one company we're we're a um
you know an association of of members
that retain their own ownership but come
together um to Market our products kind
of collectively into the space so that
um big you know big users big buyers of
sugar can see sugar beats as a solution
for large market share um soybean is
another that took 50 years to become
firmly established uh in the United
States um and a lot of that is is
credited to you know two Federated U
entities the United soy board and the
American soybean Association that were
able to look at their membership's needs
find uh find dollars to support that um
obviously we see the ad of check offs um
and what not at the farm level but there
again that has bred innovation in in
developing new products from soy and soy
oil and soy meal um in understanding you
know the nutritional value of meal um
you know all that you know Cooperative
working together for the benefit of the
entire industry um really showed a lot
of
success so we started to still some of
that down into some lessons learned for
our our supply chain um you know based
on those other learnings that
representative associations were
critical whether that was in France for
hemp or these other ADI in the US um
federating the farmers and the growers
association seems have been a very
successful uh methodology as well to uh
help stabilize the growing region you
know you diversify um you know the uh
the supply chain for more than one
farmer but everybody working together to
ensure um you know that there is a
supply and the quality of that supply
and even sharing the cost of some of the
implements or Investments and equipment
to get that done um and then
coordinating farmers and processors from
research and development from
universities and private firms right um
so there again not working in a bubble
right okay what is Meaningful to to
Farmers and I think you heard from David
shuch a lot of the research happening
there we're involved in a program to
look at microbial activity to boost
reading on hyraw uh and that's a place
where industry and Farmers stand to gain
a lot but we need universities to do
that you know a lot of that
groundbreaking
work uh generating political support the
state and federal levels um that's sort
of going hit and miss you know so far in
the United States and and we um we have
a lot of diversity in our goals a lot of
diversity in our you know large large
country and the needs in any different
region in um we need that support
collection aggregation in Sharing to
enable traceability and efficiency so
this is something obviously the cotton
industry did really well um really USDA
did really well right is they developed
grading schemes they collected data uh
on the on the quality of the of the
cotton and they developed the
methodology to and you know for
standardization and specifications and
then they developed the traceability
program so that every cotton bail you
know has a has a tag and it's traceable
right big undertaking took support of
the federal government uh we're not
likely to get that kind of support soon
but things we should be thinking about
right and then of course strategic
alliances with Industries we'll be
looking for pool like what is what do
existing Industries need and how can we
service
them um if you look at the uh the
industry right now the hemp industry um
there's there's some challenges there I
I actually we just did a a quick math on
this um right now we know of about 39
you know decortication companies you
know primary straw processors um and
they all have different scale different
equipment different regions um different
products different specifications and
it's and it's a challenge because
they're kind of all 39 of them out there
talking to a lot of the same people a
lot of the same same customers um and so
while you know um a robust supply chain
that isn't dependent on any one uh any
one player is critical um to show that
we can scale um that's a lot of Talking
Heads out there um you know talking to
the customer base and potentially confus
fusing them or or um you know possibly
stealing customer base so um you know
and because of that there's minimal
continuity and there's no stand you know
no real standard specification we had a
little bit of success lately um you know
inm and in some building codes codes but
uh we got some you know some more work
to do there and so this you know this is
all sort of come back to that
coordinating the the value chain right I
mean quality matters but it matters you
know to the customer right I mean if
we're not you know producing something
that somebody wants to buy that's that's
a problem um because at the end of the
day you we can talk about hemp we can
talk about sustainability but the the
first two metrics are price and
performance right and and if we can if
we can be competitive in price and
performance hemp's going to win almost
every time on
sustainability um you know and and the
other marketing attributes um but in
order to to solve some of these problems
we got to work together to do that and I
think it's understanding that uh how to
work in that supply chain is important
we start by first we have to understand
that value chain um then we need to work
on optimizing it and then we can grow it
and then we can increase its complexity
right I I kudos to those folks out there
you know trying to work on graphing from
hemp but like um maybe there's some
lower hanging fruit out there right and
so um we're going to need those things
there's no doubt about it but sort of
focusing on basic products and then
moving into more value ad and highly
technical attributes is a bit of a road
map that we've been uh trying to you
know trying to work on focusing on ready
customers are they importing it from out
of the country like let's start there
right just change their supply chain
from International you know to domestic
um and let's work on characterizing that
that production and uh and the raw
material and then we can increase it and
we can improve it so I think a stairstep
approach to Growing this supply chain
together is probably more likely to be
successful so we need to find value
right um for hemp and starting easy you
know start easy what's that low hanging
fruit I mean I hate to be cheeky but you
know animals pee on bedding it's not
that complicated right um we can move on
to more complicated things you know we
are a really strong advocates for hemp
as a food um but it's a difficult cell I
mean I I don't even know how to
pronounce half these words up here right
now albumin and globulin um they're not
in my frozen pizza I'm pretty sure so
you know there's a lot of work to do to
educate
uh the the consumers and the food
manufacturers out there about about how
powerful these uh these ingredients can
be but it's more complicated and it
takes more time right and so I think we
have to have this balanced approach of
loow hanging fruit and then an eye to
the future you know in more complicated
uh opportunities for
him because I guess it's a bit of a soak
box right you here you can do 10,000
usages uh for hemp but um you know what
are the 100 that'll make money that's
the bottom line right I mean like in
order to have sustainable business
models we have to have you know
profitability and so this is a you know
really great map that sort of breaks
down um entry-level project you know
products to more complicated strategic
initiatives and beginning to understand
this as an industry will help us chart
our path um you know through and
prioritize uh what we do uh in the value
chain these are long games um you know
it's we having some really good success
here recently it looks like hemp seed
meal for laying hins is about to be
approved by afo in the United States
it's a big deal and it has taken three
years to get to this point and a lot of
people working on it right you can feed
hemp to your your babies but you can't
feed it to your chickens or your cattle
um so the the long game is important but
dedicating resources to that can be
challenging and even when we participate
in that we really have to understand um
you know what is it what what does it
mean for the industry right what problem
are we trying to solve be that in the
nutritional profile for chicken or in
the co-product utilization at the
processor level right I've got a lot of
demand for hempseed oil I need to find a
place for the meal um so all these
things have to go hand inand as we look
at the market in the supply chain to
ensure that we've got uh opportunities
for you know all of the fractions are
stram that come off of the uh off the
farm and off of the processor uh we also
need to reduce barriers right for for
Growers um for processors and um you
know the idea that we still have to get
um background checks for our Farmers to
grow industrial hemp is can be a
challenge getting Farmers to grow for us
so the industrial hemp Act is an
opportunity um I encourage you guys to
take a look at this uh WR your
congressman and whatnot um but changing
the regulations a little bit to be a
little bit more friendly for grain and
fiber because if you've ever seen a
fiber field it's pretty clear they're
not growing marijuana in there right I
mean you can tell at a glance that that
is not um you know not a THC crop um so
there's a lot of opportunities there as
we look at now more into the
optimization stage this is just this is
just one of those opportunities so um
the future's wide open you know I think
uh I think you know what I'm talking
about here just sort of ways to help us
chart the path but the opportunity is is
a bit endless and I think we all have an
opportunity to write our own stories we
just we should do that together and
learn lessons uh where we can as we go
and we'll head off into the sunset so um
that's about it uh for my talk I'll see
if I can figure out how to answer some
questions
um okay so first question here um 50% of
their Farmers produce organic seeds what
are some application differences in
product for organic seeds and
non-organic seeds yeah it's a good
question um so just to be clear um you
know we would typically refer to this as
grain versus planting seeds so yeah
about 50% of our farm activity in the
past has been for organic grain it does
turn out that that straw is certified
organic as well um and our facilities
are certified organic so our our uh
grain cleaning and crushing facilities
certified organic our fiber processing
plant so uh we can sell the residual
straw organic fiber from there but to
but to your question the applications
aren't terribly different per se um it's
just a matter of whether or not that uh
that that product that brand wants
organic um or not uh so for instance we
have a a buyer of hemp seed oil that
makes condiments they're not concerned
about it being organic however we have
another buyer of hemp seed oil that
makes soaps they do want it to be
organic um so it's it's really more of
that prerogative and what market share
they're going after
functionally the uh the product is
basically the same right whether that's
um a meal for the the the hip seed meal
for the chickens organic not- Organics
just does the brand really want
organic who is the current direct
consumer how much are change over would
him be as a coin corn soybean
farmer um
so the change from like an incumbent
farming practice um you know I I like to
say that like um for for like fiber you
plant on a grain model and you you
harvest on a hay model that's probably
where most of the um most of the
differences are going to happen is going
to be in a in a fiber crop the grain
crops are pretty similar um to soybean I
mean your fertilization even isn't that
much different you're using seed drills
um you're using combines grain dryers
cleaners on the grain side it's it's
more of a drop in it's more about you
know what are the settings on the
combine and um you know what's your
favorite color red or green combine and
and what you know what changes do you
maybe have to make so that you don't
have tangling of the fiber there's
nuances there but uh but it's pretty
pretty darn similar on the grain um the
fiber more challenging where we have to
look at more specialized harvesting
equipment and so that's what I was
talking about earlier about you know
maybe a processor invest in those or
Growers associations invest in those um
the direct consumer of I guess of a
mid-tier processor Like Us in some cases
is uh retailers and Distributors for our
branded products that go on shelves or
on Amazon direct to Consumer um or uh
and the bulk of it is B2B you know we're
selling to converters like a non-woven
line or something like
that um do all your H Farmers that grow
for Grandin have drying equipment on the
farm Farm is a requirement for IND hemp
grain farm so um they don't have grain
dryer so Montana is pretty dry but they
they do have like live bins um so that
uh we can put air not not all of them
most of them have have bins with
airation in them where they can dry it
down in the bin uh what we do ask them
to do is is pre- clean um so before they
put it in the bin to get rid of a lot of
that chaff that's still in there um yeah
full floor Iration uh thanks doton um
but um but what really helps is to get
rid of a lot of that chaff so that
there's not as much moisture going into
the bin so we do ask our Farmers lots of
times to do a pre- cleaning with like a
trumel type of a
device um yeah Henry Ford and soybeans
um do you know if the new Farm Bill
addressing Industrial Hemp issues um yes
it will I don't know exactly what those
will be um so stay tuned how do you
suppose dispose of the Dust In Your Dust
collection systems Tom Keane hey buddy
man good to good to see you're still out
there in the hemp space Tom's uh I I'm
just give a shout out to Tom here
because uh Kentucky really led the
charge in the early years one of the
things that most states are missing is
support um from their extension services
right uh which all Farmers utilize so um
I don't I don't know what up to these
days Tom but Tom was the Kentucky h
specialist for the extension uh services
so um but uh at any rate to answer your
question uh we're trying to find markets
for the Dust for sure and we've got some
things out there um today we typically
just turn it back into the soil to
provide some nutritional value to our
Farmers um so we we take it out you know
in a dump truck and spread it on a field
um we have quite a few uh value added
opportunities we're working on composite
space um lawn and garden space um
erosion control
they haven't quite hit
yet what size field do we have to grow
to make it worth it that is dependent on
you know your farm operation right um
you know I think you know in the in the
old days like it's something like CBD
we're talking much smaller Acres more of
a tobacco T type of model um these days
you know with grain and fiber uh we
typically don't do anything our Farmers
don't do anything less than 40 acres um
Ian it probably makes the most sense in
the 100 to 200 acre range they grow
thousands of Acres though which maybe is
different than other parts of the
country where a farmer might grow
average like 500 Acres um our Farms can
be as much as 40,000 Acres out here in
Montana um more typically in the 10,000
acre
range um thanks
Vanessa for your your uh compliment
um okay
so this might be question beyond your
presentation agronomics um like to know
whether there's any sort of audio alepoy
with hemp I don't even know if I said
that word right um can we grow hemp in a
farm continuously or should we rotate it
um we are definitely not Advocates of of
monocropping uh with hemp I don't know
that there's any good studies out there
other than the you know sort of generic
disease cycle breaking um types of of of
components um I'm not the expert on that
but we definitely encourage rotational
crops we think that's better for the
farmer it's better for the soil you know
they can diversify their
portfolio um also hemp has a long taper
it and so an hour neck of the woods
sometimes it can be useful to break up
some of that hardpacked soil and so it's
useful to to rotate it around for that
as well um so I'm not the expert on that
but we definitely recommend uh
rotating what do you believe is the
biggest barried entry and how to
overcome that so um it's going to depend
a little bit on you know what vertical
we might be talking about uh and then
you know what uh what's been happening
in your region right if you've got um it
can start with just getting seed uh can
be a can be a barrier entry but if you
sort of gotten beyond that and you're
starting to look at uh you know how do I
make a successful business um one of the
challenges we see right now is hemp
foods are not growing very fast I mean
we kind of hit Peak hemp heart in a
sense um so you know most consumers that
that that know about hemp Foods or
eating hemp Foods in the current format
um so I think you know that's that's a
challenge on the on the food side of the
business um is finding you know is
finding markets there um the export
opportunity is growing I would say in
that case um so I think on the on the
oil seed side uh it starts with you know
what are those markets and and how do I
address them um on the fiber side you
know there's a lot of Market opportunity
those are growing pretty rapidly um you
know what I've seen in the industry is
is is capital being one of the biggest
challenges uh to be able to you know to
kind of get up and running uh to do that
and um because it's you sort of need a
walk crawl run right it's hard to invest
in large scale infrastructure if you
don't have some successful operating
supply chain and it's easier to get a
supply chain going at a smaller scale
but you can't provide Goods at a
competitive price um so you know so
there's some challenges there so it kind
of depends on you know where you're
where you're at in the supply chain if
you're at the farm level harvesting
equipment might be a big uh challenge
for you to supply fiber if you're in uh
if you want to be a processor then
getting the capital to scale may be one
of the challenges um so it depends you
know it depends but but in all cases
almost all cases at this point you know
hemp is is replacing something else
right and so um that can be a challenge
you know uh new opportunities for hemp
holy new are a little bit more difficult
so finding the those easy wins is is
critical I
think please talk about the unique
aspects of hemp supply chain branches as
they relate to seed fire building
materials and flour uh yeah Dave you
know it's a good point um we're really
big advocates for the uh for dual you
know dual cropping Dual
Purpose excuse me um and so you know uh
if you grow for grain you still have a
stalk out in the field and there are
some genetics that are more optimized to
have more stalk or more grain or whatnot
um but uh you know you can harvest the
Grain and then you can harvest the uh
the straw as well and uh the you know so
so as a plant you know that sort of
whole plant utilization is really
powerful particularly at the farm level
because the farmer has sort of the
opportunity to make two uh two revenue
streams you know the Grain and the straw
that's just more compelling to them
right um you know the infrastructure to
to process on the other hand is is
pretty different right I mean the
equipment you're going to process at
grain width is going to be different
than the straw um so it does require two
sets of infrastructure there
um but nevertheless at the farm level
they can be combined now that's not to
say that you aren't giving something up
like your yield may go down on the grain
for both the straw or the or the Grain
and your quality of the fiber might not
be as good if it's coming from a grain
crop those kinds of things but there's
still opportunities um to address a lot
of the market share you know because of
that um and so I think that is in in
some cases there are overlaps um like I
said we do a lot in the animal sector
right so when we process the straw you
know we sell bedding into equestrian and
small pets um we also have some
non-wovens for uh laying hen mats um but
then on the oil seed side you know we
have omega 369 supplements of the oil uh
protein you know protein and um and
dietary fiber that all come from the
grain so there are it's a bit of a VIN
diagram in some places but typically
you're addressing different markets
where the straw is going to more
industrial materials uh which have a you
know crazy amount of opportunities yeah
from building materials insulation uh
hemp Crete even potentially to
structural components in the future um
you know to Pulp and Paper and so on and
so forth so a lot of diversity in the
opportunity out there what's done to
eliminating pesticides or heavy metals
that might be present in the crops um
well you can't really do anything if it
is in the crop to my knowledge I mean
it's hard to remediate it after you've
you've harvested it um there was a
problem with this um in Canada a little
while back uh there was a large uh you
know a large um Market in in Korea for I
believe hemp seed oil I may butcher this
a little bit but um I wasn't instantly
involved in it but um but they changed
the regulations on on um you know some
of the uh the assay data and what think
Cobalt might have been the issue is uh
they were you know they lowered the
allowable levels of cobalt and made a
big scare you know large markets were
lost there for for hemp grain um because
once it's in there it's hard to get it
out it's you're really better off on the
front end right doing your um soil
selection and um you know and picking
soils that don't have those problems
because hemp is a phyto remediator it
will collect those heavy metals um
pesticides yeah I mean uh most
pesticides you can't use on him uh very
very few are certified so in general
enal there shouldn't be too much
pesticide usage on on the HP itself
there may be some residual in the soil
we do test for that for time to time but
there again once it's in there you can't
really get it out so it's more about um
you know Crop Production practices and
soil
selections which vertigal do you expect
to grow in the next three to five years
um definitely we see the most growth on
the fiber side um Building Materials in
automotive uh as a guy that's been in
the industry for a while
um I can tell you that it's one of the
most exciting things happened recently
uh for you know for our company and to
my knowledge it's probably the first
time in the US that a uh that that an
automotive supplier formerly asked a
hemp fiber supplier to bid on a project
um lots of talk lots of triing lots of
stuff but um we we finally got the
opportunity to actually bid on a on a
program um so I think Automotive has got
um got some potential in the future
don't know that we'll get that one I'm
not saying we're going to get it but
pretty big milestone um that that we at
least got for real opportunity to to bid
so um yeah the fiber side you know we're
seeing lots of growth for the bass fiber
that doesn't come without challenges on
the herd side so while the herd
opportunities are growing the key is
balancing the the herd Demand with the
fiber production so there are I would
say there are needs on the herd side to
grow markets to complement uh the fiber
side so wouldn't I wouldn't get too um
overly you know uh optimistic about bass
fiber because again it's all about that
co- product um utilization to make a
successful business model in finding
paths for off takes for those as
well um do your Growers all grow
according to the same spec seating rate
variety not exactly um generally yes but
yeah we do a few different varieties we
do a few different models um so yeah we
do x59 for grain uh we do uh some Asian
varieties for fiber um those change
seaing rates are much lower lower for
grain you're in the 20 25 pounds of the
acre um for fiber you're in the 50 plus
pounds of the acre fertilization changes
based on those applications and of
course whatever the soil has in it to
begin with um so we have some general
guard rails but it is on a farm byarm
basis do you have your Farmers R the
fiber crop yeah I mean we want them to
absolutely we pay more even um some
cases if it is red so uh it's pretty
important for the fiber quality to
R are there some him specific bio
remediation efforts impacts and outcomes
in your community or range of farms yeah
so this is interesting kind of going
back to that question about the uh the
heavy metals right um so there's an
opportunity for Bio or phyter mediation
but then what do you do with that
material and so there are places that
don't care where you might be able to
use that and um you know uh where that
product can make sense maybe in a
plastic or something like that um but um
so we're not seeing a lot of that right
now we um uh our our founder Ken is
working uh with a large oil company to
to do a demonstration project one of the
things I one of the endg games is um
well first it's like you plant the crop
it it remediates and then there's a few
stages of what we can do from there turn
it you know whether it's compost it turn
it into Industrial Products where they
don't care but then biochar is another
opportunity as well that we're we're
looking at um it's a good way to sequest
the carbon in um you know and sort of
triage some of those uh um you know some
of those uh heavy metals and
whatnot um and we're pretty much out of
time here I'll this one last question of
the acreage your Farmers grow how much
is irrigated Almost 100% of our fiber
acres are irrigated and almost 100% of
our grain acres are not irrigated um so
that varies by year to year uh you know
how many acres we're we're growing so so
like this year we'll have 2,000 acres or
we're targeting about 2,000 acres under
irrigation for um for
fiber so um turn it back over to you
thanks everybody for joining great
questions awesome thank you so much Trey
that was a great talk and um you
answered so many questions it was really
really useful and enlightening about uh
your work and IND hemp um and their
their role in the space so thank you
very much our next session will be in
two weeks we're going to have Dr David
Gang from Washington State University
he's going to talk about expanding the
national hemp DRM plasm collection and
supporting the hemp industry um so the
this recording will be uploaded to our
YouTube page the link for that is in the
chat you can also um Google it and um
again there's more resources on our
Cornell hemp website for you guys so
thank you for joining and I'm going to
sign off thank you Trey again thank
you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu